das hier sind 20 € und für diesen Zwanni
bekommt ihr vier Döner zwei Hamster oder
einmal Apple Kabel Kopfhörer aber was
wenn ich euch sage dass man diese 20 €
auch besser investieren kann wie wäre es
mit einem Doppelzimmer mit Dachterrasse
Pool und viele mehr und das in nichts
Geringerem als einem 5 Sterne Hotel aber
was kann ich für 20 € eigentlich
erwarten wo auf der Welt finden wir so
ein Hotel und auf welche Überraschungen
muss ich mich gefasst machen genau das
finden wir gemeinsam heraus in ich habe
das günstigste fünf Sterne Hotel der
Welt getestet auf der Suche wird relativ
schnell klar dass wir nicht in Europa
und schon gar nicht in Deutschland finde
ich werden nach ewiger Recherche auf
etlichen Reiseportalen auf tiktok auf
ganz vielen verschiedenen Plattformen
sind wir dann tatsächlich fündig
geworden 16 Euro 5 Sterne Hotel in
Bangkok mit Pool mit Gym und allem was
man sich vorstellen kann zumindest steht
es für eine Anzeige der Preis ist
eigentlich zu schön um wahr zu sein wenn
man bedenkt dass man für 16 € in den
meisten Hotels in Deutschland nicht mal
einen Platz am frühstücken bekommt und
schon gar keine Nacht in dem eigenen
Zimmer wie finden wir nun aber heraus ob
das Versprechen tatsächlich eingehalten
werden kann ob dieses Hotel existiert
und vor allem ob da nicht noch
irgendwelche versteckten Kosten auf uns
zukommt ganz einfach Sachen packen ab in
den Flieger und nach Bangkok Thailand
also ich habe ja wirklich schon vieles
Erlebnis ne aber das hier in irgendeinem
Hinterhof in Bangkok 16 € 5 Sterne ich
könnte nicht gespannter sein wir haben
so ziemlich am oberen Ende alles
getestet was geht und auch für 11 € ein
Hotel in Deutschland das so war wie man
sich in 11 € Teil vorstellt aber was
kann jetzt dieses 16 Euro 5 Sterne Hotel
die Bilder sind gut aus wir checken ein
und gucken
nicht besonders vielversprechend
vielleicht hat das Ganze aber auch gar
nicht so viel zu bedeuten wir nehmen
unsere Schlüssel machen uns auf den Weg
in den fünften
stockart das ist schon mal ein Vorteil
gegenüber das günstige Hotels in
Deutschland was wir mit Schlüssel
geöffnet haben und äh im Zweifelsfall
ist in diesem Hotel auch der Mülleimer
gelernt im Gegensatz zu dem in
Deutschland und wir lassen uns mal
überraschen
Eingangsbereich hä
10 von 10
[Musik]
also bevor wir uns im Pool angucken und
bevor wir uns wirklich eine Meinung
machen können und es mit dem günstigsten
Hotel in Deutschland vergleichen können
erstmal bewegliche roomtour hier vorne
Eingangsbereich genug Platz um auch
neben der Tür noch die Koffer
abzustellen von dort geht es sofort ins
Badezimmer und dann kommt man hier rein
wir haben relativ also ziemlich neues
Badezimmer ein Waschbecken wir haben
genug Platz wir haben eine Toilette
alles ist sauber wir haben eine
bodentiefe Dusche natürlich sieht man
hier in den Ecken so ein bisschen was
aber auch das ist man aus Thailand
gewohnt und dann geht's aus dem Bett
weiter wir haben Bademantel wir haben
Schlappen wir haben ein ziemlich
geräumigen Raum im Klimaanlage wir haben
den Fernseher wir haben einen Safe
gut den Safe könnte man einfach mit
rausnehmen und hätte alles was von
bräuchtet jetzt nicht wie sicher der ist
wir haben eine Minibar wir haben einen
Mülleimer der Müll ist geleert riesen
Pluspunkt zu dem in Deutschland ist das
Zimmer schick wir haben Tee Kaffee ein
großes Bett i don't know what more to
ask for um ehrlich zu sein ist das
Zimmer fünf Sterne weiß ich jetzt nicht
gibt es vielleicht etwas anderes in dem
Hotel was ist zu einem fünf Sterne Hotel
machen könnte vermutlich aber lasst uns
das gemeinsam herausfinden nachdem uns
das Zimmer für den Preis schon mal mehr
als überrascht hat ging es jetzt daran
den Wohlfühlfaktor des Hotels zu testen
es geht bei fünf Sternen nämlich um mehr
als nur das Zimmer und die Minibar 5
Sterne versprechen eine rundum sorglos
gefühlt und damit ihr euch beim Gedanken
an eure Finanzen in Zukunft gibt es
gelbe capital dem Partner des heutigen
Videos gelbe capital ist nicht nur mein
persönlicher Broker sondern auch
finanzfluss Testsieger mit der App oder
sogar der Desktop-Version könnt ihr ganz
bequem in Aktien ETFs und eine Vielzahl
weiterer Finanzprodukte investieren die
Erstellung eines Accounts ist im
Handumdrehen erledigt komplett
kostenfrei und ihr könnt schon ab einem
Euro in Aktien Krypto und ETF-Sparpläne
investieren mit einer Trading Flatrate
fallen die eh schon geringen
Ordergebühren von nur 99 Cent dann auch
noch weg das beste ist aber mit dem
Prime plus Broker gibt es 2,3% Zinsen
auf euer Guthaben bis 100.000 €. euer
Guthaben ist das Geld dass er bei
scalable capital eingezahlt aber noch
nicht investiert hat was bedeutet ihr
müsst nicht mal irgendein Finanzprodukt
kaufen um diese 2,3 % Zinsen zu bekommen
sondern euer Geld einfach nur einzahlen
wenn ihr also mit dem Gedanken spielt
mit dem investieren anfangen einen neuen
Broker sucht oder euch einfach mal mit
der App vertraut machen wollt dann macht
das über den ersten Link in der
Videobeschreibung und ladet euch
scalable capital herunter und wie immer
Geld startet in eurem eigenen Tempo und
informiert euch bevor ihr investiert und
das meine ich wirklich ernst guck
finanzfluss Videos von anderen Youtubern
und sammelt Informationen an
verschiedenen Stellen vielen Dank an
scalables möglich machen dieses Videos
alle wichtigen Links findet ihr unten in
der Videobeschreibung und für mich heißt
es jetzt Bademantel und Badeschlappen an
und ab aufs Dach denn was uns dort
erwartet hat war wirklich krank
also jetzt mal ganz im Ernst vielleicht
ist es nicht fünf Sterne aber
das ist auf jeden Fall mehr als 16 Euro
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ein ganz ehrlich zu sein hat man
hier so richtige New York Vibes das
wirkt wie so ein Raum der eigentlichen
Atelier sein sollte
360 Grad in einer mega Metropole und das
ist einfach für so wenig Geld irgendwie
fühlt sich das falsch an aber genau das
ist Bangkok genauso habe ich Bangkok
kennengelernt immer für eine
Überraschung gut und vor allem einfach
unheimlich günstig und jetzt geht es zum
Pool
[Musik]
fehlen die Worte
Barbecue Bereich da vorne ist vermutlich
eine autoküche die man selber benutzen
kann dann
geht es hier die Treppen hoch
Digger
und dann stehen wir am 16 Euro 5 Sterne
Hotel Pool in Bangkok Infinity Pool in
Bangkok also ich glaube wir hatten noch
bei keinem anderen Hotel so einen guten
Blick
das habe ich auch in vollen Zügen
genossen bis ich Durst bekommen habe und
mich nach einer Bar umgeschaut habe die
ich nicht finden konnte das ist einzige
was ich finden konnte war ein
verschlossener Kühlschrank also wirklich
abgeschlossen keine Möglichkeit
irgendwie für uns angekühlte Getränke zu
kommen und auch am Abend es gab kein
Essen kein Restaurant im gesamten Hotel
nachdem wir nun das Hotel ausgiebig
getestet haben geschwommen sind keine
Kaltgetränke genießen konnten gibt es
jetzt an die Bewertung des Hotels die
Bewertung des günstigsten fünf Sterne
Hotels der gesamten Welt das Zimmer ist
für mich eine dreieinhalb von fünf unter
anderem der Tatsache dass wir eigentlich
ein fünf Sterne ein wirkliches fünf
Sterne Hotelzimmer erwarten können weil
es so ausgeschrieben war Match das nicht
so ganz grundsätzlich alles war im
Zimmer verfügbar es war okay sauber es
war nicht mega sauber aber es war okay
und für den Preis ist es garantiert
besser als der Durchschnitt also 3,5 der
Service ließ etwas zu wünschen übrig bei
fünf Sternen erwartet man Roomservice
Getränke am Pool oder sogar jemanden
Angestellten am Pool der einem die
Getränke bringt oder wie auch immer all
das gab es nicht so richtig es gab eine
nette Bedienung unten am Schalter aber
eigentlich kann man da schon fast nicht
von Service sprechen ein von fünf
Sternen und bei der Verpflegung geht es
direkt genauso weiter wir hätten gutes
Restaurant erwartet wir hätten Frühstück
erwartet aber all das war aus ominösen
Gründen einfach geschlossen und es gab
für uns nichts zu essen Vorteil wir sind
in Bangkok man geht auf die Straße es
gibt street food und alles ist bestens
für den preis gebe ich einfach mal auch
durch den Standortvorteil zweieinhalb
von fünf Sterne weil wir sehr gut
gegessen haben ohne dass wir wirklich im
Hotel essen mussten würde ich rein das
Hotel bewerten müssten es null von fünf
sein aber das finde ich für den Preis
irgendwie nicht so richtig fair und
vielleicht haben sie sich ja auch aktiv
dazu entschieden kein Essen anzubieten
weil das street food direkt vor der Tür
besser ist als das was sie hinbekommen
haben bei der Sauberkeit kann ich
überhaupt nicht meckern und das ganze
bewerte ich aus einem Thailand Standard
aus der Sicht von jemanden der schon
einige Nächte in verschiedenen Hotels
und verschiedenen Unterbringung in
Thailand auch in Bangkok geschlafen hat
das war absoluter Durchschnitt wenn
nicht sogar ein bisschen drüber vier von
fünf Sternen auch wenn es vielleicht
kleinere Problemchen gibt wie
rausguckende Nägel in dem Bereich wo man
eigentlich barfuß am Pool unterwegs ist
das zählen wir einfach mal nicht mit
rein die Lage absolut top Bangkok ist
super vernetzt man kann super günstig
von A nach B kommen wir sind in einer
mega Metropole also viel mehr geht
eigentlich nicht ich muss 55 geben und
bei der Aussicht vom Pool ist das mehr
als gerechtfertigt und was soll ich
sagen beim Preis geht es natürlich
genauso weiter 55 Sternen viel mehr geht
nicht also offensichtlich geht nicht
viel mehr das war eins der günstigsten
Hotels dass ich jemals gebucht habe und
mit Abstand dass das am meisten geboten
hat von all den günstigen Hotels in
denen ich jemals geschlafen habe eine
absolute Top Erfahrung richtig geiler
Pool die sind Zimmer Verpflegung
bisschen schwierig aber all in all war
das Hammer gut und eine sehr witzige und
coole Erfahrung wenn ihr andere
verrückte Hotels kennt die ich mal
testen sollte dann lasst es mich in den
Kommentaren wissen vergiss nicht den
Kanal zu abonnieren um die kommenden
Videos nicht zu verpassen wir sehen uns
in den nächsten Tagen wieder
[Musik]